okay so what what we're doing is uh
we're tempting the mind
to stay in that first mind aspect in the
functioning of the ego tripartite
by generating uh the fear and triggering
the fear response and the world's power
reactivity
okay um and it doesn't take much to do
that to people
okay so you can keep this
in a normal let's say one person so a
normal g
was uh and uh we're just going
in i'm not over here predicting ahead of
time
that's not what i'm doing as as he
triggers my mind
right here he triggered he triggered me
and got the will to power
and so in in that is where i do my
release
and find the technique
okay something different would be
me predicting ahead of time and you're
just taking advantage of knowing what's
coming in
if this technique is so simple that this
g was this
environment is so simple that you have
to
not predict you have to release
and then secondly um you're never
muscling you're never muscling
okay but some don't realize that they
don't
they don't see that so we add a second
guy
and that would be enough to amplify and
make visible
so i'm going and you see i'm stuck on
him
you see as i pick my technique
the mind has to find the uh
so
so you see i never lose the other guy
my mind is constantly releasing
okay let's try it the mine's on andrew
and you lost strength
so don't wait you need to wait
okay so uh
[Music]
so she goes and she's counting
come on
this is that practice where um
they don't get to decide you get it
um so you're
you were tasked with getting him
so we see his triggerability
but you tasked yourself with defending
yourself
okay so
but you can make that part of your
training
because you make everything work
okay without it getting
it okay got it but
he will get better and you will not
okay all right try it again
so in the gu you're you're coming and
you're trying to do
the uh nugget but when the person is
countering you
and you you lose you fail okay or
when we have the two attackers and
you're over here
and you're trying to muscle them you get
pinned and when you get pinned you get
delayed and the second attacker catches
captaincy
okay so we're going to go into that
technique a little bit
and so let's just look at poke hole
and uh what's actually happening okay
so if he if i'm here
and i leverage him up
and then try to throw him
we do that technique like this this
is now i have been pinned
second guy is going to catch me
what we want to do instead is not have
two young arms
but one yin arm okay
so i keep his energy going on one side
that's what starts to tilt
if you look here he's just square and
so a lot of times when they're allowed
to counter
because his posture is not compromised
and he counters he can
he can do it especially when he lets go
double leg
oh then i'm in trouble
so the best thing is just do jiu jitsu
don't contest
let the energy go by
and you'll see one shoulder straight
places and he's already going into the
front kazushi
but i
am not just gonna let let him swing out
of the way
so i'll show you what i mean okay uh
you can let go and he's not
coming forward it doesn't matter
he i have the adhesion okay
so it's not a passive i'm here and i get
out of the way
you see because he has control of his
feet
where he steps only the choreographed uk
goes ahead and checks himself
but if i don't have his body he can do
whatever he wants right so he goes i'll
move on the way he does whatever he
wants can you counter
so when i when i'm here i have to have
his body
so it is a yielding but there's an
adhesion which you guys should we're
going to show that
he's not pushing anymore and it doesn't
matter
[Music]
oh
this is different
usually they're coming forward that's
when you would do the technique but just
becoming
just because he's coming forward don't
just
keep him in perfect agency
so we're going to have him not come
forward
and i'm going to do
the adhesion so yes it is a yielding
but it has integrity against other
angles okay let's go
okay so as he's coming in uh you can see
i'm on this side of the
of the uh action sorry let's get your
one you were right okay i'm not on this
side
and then i'm pushing
so i i'm on this side of the thing you
see on this side and then
that is important because if i have to
be on
the other side of the circle all the
time and movement that it takes to get
there i don't have the same
control of his body i'm over here
this is where all that's happening
secondly uh keep your grip all weird
okay i don't want to use his
grip as a kind of anchor point
i do because that meant i gave them time
to grab me
and i don't want him to i don't want him
to get a good grip
so in this drill he's just here and i'm
good
[Music]
so a lot of times on the second guy
you're like they got a good crab on you
and the second guy got you so
it's all about don't let him grab you
when you're going into you
so i kind of feel fill his palm do you
see that can you see that
i'm not here and up at his forearm
so i'm going into his head boom
it is adhering before he gets there
[Music]
okay okay so in this drill
i'm gonna work on not letting him get
his grip okay
then i'm going to test for the ikea
adhesion
by having him pull okay
now the earlier i get that ik adhesion
the earlier i have control over his his
body you see
the later such that the more
it doesn't happen until i'm on the other
side of the circle
that's where you get counter in all that
time that he's moving
and you don't have control and then you
try to do your throw gear
the counterable phuket counters
because you didn't have control of them
they're not tilted
there there's no angle of cancellation
on their body
they're just walking in this all this is
no control no control then
he voluntarily culturally
gives up his front foot in the way that
the countering uke ng was that does not
you get it so in our drill you need to
have the adhesion
not there's no adhesion let's say and
i'm like i
will i move forward i move forward to
here
you see this is too late so you you want
to try to get it as far out as possible
in the drill
so won't got it and then also as
early as possible so i'm out here but
look
tick tick tick tick tick uh
it's not gonna be applicable so right
away
right away as soon as you touch
it okay and out
right away and out as far as possible go
okay so
in in the push
we'll go back to the push but there
there's that same sense that that's
what's happening
it's not just me yielding out of the way
and then like i pulled the chair out
from under him and he fell down
i got out of the way and he came forward
that's not what's happening
okay so right away and now all i got to
do with that hand
is continue to take him into the shape
of the front
inward kazushi so don't
do don't leave it up here because i did
have the adhesion but i didn't keep the
tilt going
so tilt tilt tilt tilt tilt down
fully aware that the lower his head
gets the easier it is for the hip to
cross over
that line then less
energy or strength i need to
get him all the way into the kazushi so
if i leave this here
this hand has to go really far over to
make that
uh left hip take that geometry from
falling
so i'm going i'm going to lower it
to get his head low
lower it to get his head up
boom lower it to get his head down
and low
okay now this is where you'll return to
your external stuff all right and again
the guy's going to counter you or slow
you down enough to the second uk gets
you
right um or you just won't have the
mechanics for for doing the technique so
when you're over here and you're going
like this
this is all just leverage
right and so you could he could change
let's say i'm in the position right if i
go over here like this there's no
controlling him so this is where the
counter you can get
something else okay so here i already
have control so
we're going to show that i have control
that he will
give him different angles so uh let's
say he wants to come forward
before i want to you can and what you're
going to see when i say he can't
is it shifts his line of gravity and he
has to move his base of support
okay so uh in other words if he uh
tries to pull back it's not that i'm
over here
it's that when i have the adhesion it
tries to pull back it
affects his line of gravity okay so as
i'm going you're gonna see that i don't
ever get
on to the other side and now make this a
push
move it's it's all an adhesion
okay so let's let's have him uh
lift up against the adhesion
uh and we're going let's let's have him
uh
try to bring his foot this foot forward
yeah
to get your face back under you do it
again there you go okay i'll do the
adhesion
just take some more into it
so you have to watch the difference that
you're not over here and you're going
like that
that will just go and it looks like it
looks like it's going to work but it
doesn't
as you as you've noticed okay so instead
it's here you have the adhesion
and you're just using that adhesion on
that hat wall
adhesion
okay let's go okay
so as i as i do this technique
i i don't want to get on this side and
then push this down
it's going to be a leverage move
so this this hand's got the connection
let's show it by you resisting this
hand's got the connection
and what i'm going to do is you can see
that i'm making his mask move towards me
and it's going to hit the cue so
he's going to come in again and i have
the adhesion on this hand
and i'm going to manipulate him so
boom he hits this hand
so again the eye adhesion
we'll do the one below will you get on
okay so
uh i have the adhesion go a little
slower a little slower
i have the adhesion oh and this arm here
i want his weight to hit
that front ground path so
boom huh
does it matter
can be long can be short
can't get his head as low as possible so
the hip goes over
easier okay let's go